la jueza de distrito el in canon reveló
un inventario detallado de los
documentos que allanó el fbi en la
mansión de mar a lago de donald trump en
la florida el 8 de agosto en el
documento legal de 11 páginas se indica
como parte del material confidencial
estaba mezclado en cajas con artículos
de periódicos y de revistas de los
documentos que estaban marcados como
clasificados 18 eran secretos de estados
54 estaban marcados como secreto y 31
documentos eran confidenciales además se
encontraron 48 carpetas vacías que
también estaban marcadas como
clasificadas pero no se sabe muy bien
qué información estaba ahí quien pudo
haber tenido acceso a esta puede
resaltar que se recuperaron también
cerca de 11.000 documentos que no
estaban marcados como confidenciales en
una nota a la corte el departamento de
justicia informó que ya revisó todos
estos documentos recuperados y sin
embargo aclaró que esta información
seguirá siendo parte de la investigación
criminal en curso sobre el manejo de los
documentos confidenciales que podrían
derivar incluso en formulación de cargos
contra el ex presidente don ottón